weathers in Maryland hi Randy welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave it's nice
to talk to you you too what's up so I
wanted your advice because I have an
appointment at 1:45 tomorrow to meet
with a lawyer for filing chapter 7
bankruptcy because I feel like that my
only way out at this point
tough times huh yeah you could say that
you're single no I'm married and I have
four children under the age of five so
you and your husband are filing
bankruptcy no I'm filing individually
because where we're at right now
basically I've owned up and said that
the debt that I've occurred and or just
yeah made it my fault because I was
keeping it a secret from my husband for
a few years he knew about the medical
debt because I have a lot of medical
issues that I'm dealing with so I'm
filing individually to try to relieve
our family of the problems that I've
caused how long have you been married
it'll be six years in November and
during that time you ran up the debt I
just been within the last three years
that I was keeping it a secret before it
was about $14,000 and we got it almost
completely paid off we were following
their plan and then so I don't mean to
get emotional a big major thing happened
in my life I got involved in a really
big court case where I had to testify
against my stepfather for the child
abuse that happened to me and so that
kind of came as a big trigger for me and
henceforth came this spending of kind of
failed and heinous
and I was trying to fill it with things
because I felt really lost try to feel
better and how much dad did you run up
I am called $28,000 in consumer $2,000
about his medical he knows about the
matter sorry so $34,000 28 consumer 6000
medical apologize and do you work
outside the home no I can't due to
mental illness I was actually just
really strong in the hospital on
September 6 a trigger warning for your
listeners I tried to commit suicide
because I felt like there was no safe
for me and now that I have diagnosed the
incident that I have severe bipolar
disorder and really impulsively haters
and a lot of issues that I'm getting
things taken care of when I've already
cancelled all the credit cards so
there's no using of any more for me I
know that much what does what's your
husband make a year
he makes $50,000 a year he's in the
military
it makes how much 55 zero okay yes and
you're seeing a counselor or therapist I
assume or two or three right yeah three
of them specifically and then one for
just medication I'm not able to see two
of them though because we can't afford
the gas and the tolls here in Maryland
for me to try to see them so I flipped
on hold for now unfortunately the first
concern is you okay you getting better
you getting well you being here you
being with your husband
you are the first concern and whatever
you and your husband
prayerfully need to do to take care of
you that's what you do okay yeah and
there's there's no shame in whatever
that is because you're in a series of
extreme situations and so you have to
take great self-care in those situations
to keep from letting things unravel
further in your life
agreed exactly
and if the removal of this debt does
that by the chapter seven that's fine
that's fine
I don't mind okay I ninety-nine percent
of time don't recommend bankruptcy and I
don't recommend it here but I am more
concerned about you than I am allows you
twenty eight thousand dollars in credit
card debt or whether you have damaged
credit for the next ten years
whoopty doopty in the scope of things if
you get well and you get past what
you've been through as a child and you
get past the struggles that you've had
recently and you can get wholeness in
your life again and spiritually and
emotionally walk this out that's all
that matters okay okay let's do that
whatever that is now if and I can't do
that
I can't do what I'm getting ready to say
in a three minute radio call I'm not
sure I can do it at all because I'm
probably not qualified but if you're a
husband and you and your therapist
decided that you guys wanted to fight
your way through this the math on this
is doable you can turn this around and
you can pay these people you can
probably settle with them you're
probably behind with them and you
probably go through and work your way
through this and I will assign a coach
to you for free of charge if you want to
try to work your way through it and if
that and if working your way through it
isn't damaging but instead adds dignity
to your eye your healing then we'll
participate in that but I don't
want to lay a guilt trip on you and
crush you okay okay and I don't know
where you're I don't know how fragile
you are it's obvious you've been through
hell okay
and I don't want to take somebody that's
fragile and dump a guilt trip on them
over a lousy little pile of credit-card
debt when life is more important than
that so start again start fresh wipe the
slate clean if that's what you want to
do if you've got the strength
wipe it fresh and reject I wanted to
wipe it fresh from me because of what
I've done I get that I get that but if
I'm your husband I can put my arms
around you and just say you're forgiven
Tara it's wiped fresh now let's go work
and pay it off but that has to do with
how your relationship with him is if
your therapist thinks you've got the
strength to do that and if that becomes
an integral part of your healing not if
that crush issue and put you back in the
suicide ward again okay
but you know you you need to get the wet
noodle and put it up you're beating
yourself enough okay it's just some
credit card debt it's Jim woopty doopty
lots of people have done stupider stuff
in the last two hours on this show hmm
okay you're not near the front of the
line of stupid you're not even close to
the front of the line you just did you
know you you have a tremendously toxic
situation that you came out of as a
child and and so you had some shame
based deception and spending whoopee
lots of people do you've realized it I
suspect listening to you you'll never do
it again because it wasn't fruitful was
it so forgive yourself okay I forgive
you your husband probably has okay thank
you means a lot coming from you I
appreciate it just I mean we've all done
I mean I went through bankruptcy when I
was 28 I had to go through these exact
same emotions but from a different
foundational viewpoint but I had to go
had gum Dave you thought you were smart
and you were stupid and it took me a
while to get my confidence back after
getting the legs knocked down from under
me my knees broken you know what I'm
saying and so this has everything if
you've got the relationship with your
therapist and your husband to work this
through you hold on Madison will pick up
and will assign a coach to you free of
charge at my expense if you don't and
you want to file tomorrow you and I are
still best friends and I'll still walk
with you through the through your new
future either ones fine this is the Dave
Ramsey show